si el primero en ofrecer su discurso ha
sido como viene siendo tradición el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro
quien ha llegado en medio de una fuerte
polémica porque como sabéis se niega a
vacunarse a pesar de que las autoridades
de nueva york habían pedido en múltiples
ocasiones a los asistentes a esta
asamblea general que se vacunarán antes
de acceder al edificio de las naciones
unidas- ya hay bolsonaro ha utilizado su
discurso para arremeter contra los
remedios sin eficacia ha dicho contra la
cob y 19 ha dicho el mismo se contagió y
se curó simplemente con medicinas además
también ha tenido un momento para
recordar que el pueblo brasileño
preserva su naturaleza a pesar de que él
haya sido ampliamente criticado por la
gestión en la deforestación y en los
incendios en su país a continuación
hemos escuchado al presidente de los
eeuu joe biden quien ha comenzado su
discurso anunciando que cierra un
periodo de guerra implacable y ha
prometido arrancar a abrir un nuevo
periodo de diplomacia implacable sobre
todo ahora con la salida de afganistán
en un intento de dejar atrás el estilo
de su antecesor de donald trump ha
apostado por el multilateralismo y se va
a centrar lo ha hecho en la diplomacia
además biden ha pedido a los países de
todo el mundo que protejan a las mujeres
ya las niñas ya todos los grupos
sociales en todos los países ha
defendido los esfuerzos por extender la
vacunación entre todos en todo el mundo
no solamente en los países ricos sino
también en los pobres y además ha dicho
que está altamente comprometido con el
acuerdo de parís sobre ese cambio
climático y que doblará su aportación
financiera internacional a la lucha
contra la crisis climática además ha
asegurado que la violencia será siempre
el último recurso